yes happy Tuesday everybody up this is
great
good to see you all and I mean that some
of you so how about some economic news I
know it sounds boring but it's important
but also Larry Kudlow is here and we
have to justify the car service and the
free meal
those frozen pizza rolls add up
not to mention the back rub I just gave
him in my office
you know Larry how about shaving that
jungle once in a while
I said close to you this is what
happened it does it does your your
magnetism is overpowering all right so
inflation is bad it's really bad prices
are still up 10 from last year with
Dallas the Twin Cities and Baltimore
suffering the biggest increases it's so
bad in Texas that Fort Worth is now Fort
worthless
it's so bad in Dallas a 10 gallon hat
now holds only eight
the Twin Cities added a third City to
cover the rent
at Baltimore well Baltimore sucks
I mean it doesn't matter
but how bad is it across the board well
have you had breakfast lately at Bed and
Breakfast it costs more for the eggs
benedict than the bed couples are saving
up for a weekend getaway to Denny's
but after witnessing High egg prices
Americans are now opting to raise their
own chickens to avoid the pain in the
wallet it's true I'm sitting on three
nests in my office alone
for a variety of reasons
the price for a carton the price for a
carton of eggs is up 60 year over year
according to the latest Consumer Price
Index if this trend continues all the
way to Halloween vandals will throw
something less expensive like iPhones
but ads are just one example out of a
ton of items that eat further into
Americans budgets than they did a few
years ago meanwhile 8 million Americans
are living paycheck to paycheck and they
make more than 100 Grand a year which
used to be the income threshold for
living the American dream or for cat to
return a guy's calls
so how is this possible
well it's something called inflation
which eats away at your earnings like
Anna Navarro through a graham cracker
crust
sorry Ann you're my new stelter
for now anyway we'll see how it works
out doesn't work out I'm dumping you
so your paycheck will say one thing but
to store shelves in the gas pump just
laughs and Joe Biden's economy your pay
stub is shrinking like your junk in a
cold Plunge
oh
it's a man's joke
meanwhile gas prices have jumped for
five straight weeks and like Pelosi's
eyebrows unlikely to drop soon
you know that's bad news for Larry he
bathes every morning in Sunoco 2000.
and the ethanol keeps his coat shiny and
clean
and what's our president up to I mean
other than reading at a fourth grade
level
good question while our economy is going
to hell in a Prius he's touting
e-vehicle tax credits tweeting out an
old pic of him at a luxury Hummer from
2021. FYI it happens to be a vehicle
that gets one wheel Revolution to the
gallon way to lead by example stupid
and high gas prices he doesn't mind
those he's got the key to Amtrak
every time I see a train door open
I head for it I used to about uh
15 of the time ride with the engineers
for real
and I'm the only guy that I was aware of
when I stopped riding Amtrak that had a
key to get in the back
that's a great story Grandpa
real I mean really tell us more like how
the Pan Am Pilots used to let you fly
the plane blindfolded when you were 12.
and how you once steered a homemade
submarine from Okinawa to Palm Springs
and Corn Pop was your first mate
about that three hour tour on that
little yacht with Gilligan
how about it Joe
Nobody Rides Amtrak like me man nobody
and I got my special key
this is my own special seat man nobody
else's it's all mine you know why
because I got my key
[Music]
everybody except me man
it's all mine
it's another place I get a lot of work
done you know why
because I have the key
[Applause]
that was beautiful
with leadership like that it's so
surprised Americans are fed up with the
government and inflation a new Gallup
poll the kind conducted by horses Larry
finds that more Americans name the
government as the nation's top problem
with inflation coming in second place so
this shouldn't be surprising to anyone
who took a basic econ class sorry cat
you're going to have to sit this part
out
but it's pretty simple you print lots of
money money becomes less valuable so you
need more of it to pay for stuff they
were sensible people pointing out the
Folly of all this but they were
outnumbered and not just by democrats
but Republicans too they threw so much
cash around drunken Sailors got
concerned but to be fair how much Choice
did they have during covet if you didn't
say yes to every so-called solution or
plan you were deemed evil I didn't mind
because I've been called evil since that
time my head spun completely around
during my baptism
but have you raised any objections to
moratoriums on rent or trillions in
stimulus it was clear you wanted people
to live on the streets or die from
disease so we can point fingers at Joe
we can point fingers at Trump but we
also got to look in the mirror we made
this bed of worthless money and we got a
lie in it just think of it as an orgy
with former presidents and when we wake
up there won't be any eggs for breakfast
[Applause]
welcome tonight's guess he's got more
money than that tooth fairy Joseph
Kudlow on Fox Business Larry Kudlow
she knows political campaigns like I
know varicose veins my legs are a road
map Republican strategist Aaron perini
his name is die which is ironic because
he kills comedian Jeff dye
it's like they always say you can take
the girl out of Detroit but she'll
probably get arrested for kidnapping
Fox News contributor captain
Larry I know you're probably still
basking in the Brilliance of that
monologue good oh thank you it was on
target
too much money chasing too few goods
well let me ask you this okay I think I
could be an economist if I my theory is
if can't you just print more money
because let's say it costs 10 bucks for
a carton of eggs and then it becomes 10
bucks per egg just raise everyone's
salary and print more money you could do
this forever and then you just have an
equilibrium
can you do that it kind of was okay more
or less before the equilibrium part yeah
you have to walk through that for me
there is a statute of limitation on
these things yes and by the way part of
its politics so people are very unhappy
and they're unhappy with inflation and
they're unhappy with high interest rates
and they're unhappy with what looks to
be a pending recession and it may be a
difficult recession I don't like to say
that I like to be The Optimist yeah
right now the tea leaves are now looking
good even the tea is very very expensive
that is true I stopped drinking tea no
that's a straight gin uh are we gonna
have a really bad reception recession as
bad as the 70s it is possible it is
possible but some of it depends on you
know whether budget restraint kicks back
in whether the federal government stops
attacking businesses or oil and gas
whether Joe Biden can figure out you
know that hummer he was in didn't even
qualify for his own Electric Vehicle tax
credit oh yeah it's amazing really yeah
yeah you know Joe just let Hunter deal
with the Hummers
yes I don't know what you I would say he
likes big cars
Jesus and
all right Aaron
what's up with the eggs I I don't you
know there's a number of things there
was an avian flu outbreak right we had
to kill a lot of chickens the price of
eggs have gone up we had to choke a lot
of chickens
this audience tonight oh my goodness I'm
sorry that's my last sexual innuendo for
this moment that's right
yeah we did a long pandemic also
inflation is a direct result of the
failure of the Biden agenda and the
Biden economy right and he talks about
how Ukraine and the war is part of the
reason that costs are going up that's
also a direct result of Joe Biden's
geopolitical failures right if he hadn't
capitulated to Putin on Nord Street 2
and gifted him a pipeline to be able to
circumvent Ukraine we likely wouldn't
have a war we likely wouldn't be having
him be able to use that as an excuse for
inflation although we know the
outrageous spending we saw in D.C is a
direct reflection of the inflation the
American people are facing and that's
why no one trusts government inflation's
a problem immigration is a problem and
it's the result of democrat policies in
D.C all righty
all right Jeff welcome back to the
program I know that you were on you were
on that show that got bumped during the
hurricane yeah my friends didn't even
believe me yes exactly like I'm gonna be
on tonight they're like no you we didn't
see you yes
I hope that doesn't happen again
although the weather does look very bad
so this probably won't air again and
you'll never you'll never see the
lighted TV just remain believing I'm a
liar what do you uh what do you make of
the chicken situation have you been
thinking about this have you noticed
when you have your brunch
no I'm a single 40 year old man you
could tell me eggs were a thousand
dollars I'd be like that checks out
right
it's a lot of cereal and bagel bites on
my it's like a single dad's Thanksgiving
at my house yes but without the kids
exactly yeah yeah also um maybe you guys
should consider what California is doing
our politicians are very very good you
know we don't worry about this inflation
stuff we don't worry much eggs cost uh
we just you you can steal it and then
take it out of the store and no one will
do anything about it yeah that's true
that is they can't get you just steal it
that is true what we're suckers for
complaining about the price of eggs we
should just take them Jack them and
they're not locked up yeah the eggs are
not locked up you can just go and you
know what just grab one if you want yeah
what are they going to enforce stealing
yeah exactly you know we want to chase
you over an egg yeah they're busy with
Cove and stuff that's so weak that is so
busy egg looting yeah ah you know what
we really blew it tonight we could have
done an egg looting skit next time next
I'm back yeah this problem isn't going
away much like you cat
what's going on here
that was a compliment
so um you obviously as a Libertarian
find this spending to be insane it
really is theft when you think about it
because like for example you have to
think about it that hard yeah I make
money they take it yes but that's
stealing but inflation is this other
Beast that takes a two yeah and yet
people don't like people don't think
about it because they don't see it I had
somebody ask me what inflation was and I
said kill Mead
I feel like get it together you're on a
morning talk show I know it doesn't
matter it's fox and friends but you see
my point like people don't see inflation
until it's too late right and you're
right the entire time we're saying hey
we're spending kind of a lot of money
here you know they say we're evil people
we want everyone to sick and die when
get sick and die when in reality there
are very few people I want to get sick
and die
um probably no one well uh well a few
one on this panel a few
um but this whole article like how bad
are things that people are like the
solution is buying a bunch of chickens
yeah how do you get there yeah like the
article was like and then people realize
it's harder than you thought who thought
it would be easy yeah and also like
congrats on having a yard yeah I know
throw that in our face yeah like so if I
were to set up a chicken coop I would
have nowhere to do it yeah that you
should though in your apartment that
would be hilarious because you have a
cat and a dog you could have a little a
little chicken yeah I just they're like
it's not you're not they're not saving
any money by raising the chicken how
many eggs does a chicken produce not a
lot in the cold weather billions I don't
know
Chicken in an apartment Larry oh that
just means that that just means the it's
not caged that's yeah the cage is just
an inch longer wouldn't it be funny if
we find out that they love cages yeah
yeah even it's wrong the whole time
been wrong the whole time about cages
but the trick is this could have been so
easily avoided you know so there's a lot
of pain that's gonna happen here and
people are furious at Washington in
general Biden in particular look go back
to your first thing too much money
chasing too few goods okay you're right
what if you produced more what if you
created lower taxes for a change what if
you produce more goods and services
fridge what if you grew the economy and
had a genuine Prosperity you wouldn't
worry about inflation it would go away
which is what it's supposed to do that's
the trouble the country is stagnant it
hasn't grown in 25 years it's not
survived it's not good it could have
been avoided yeah now you're right hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else